two weeks after a family member was
Swept Away by the flood the igas are
still waiting for the water to recede so
they can bury him
enough till
nowhere to bury him everywhere from uh
from the level of water here it could be
at least a week before they are able to
do that
many other families are waiting for news
any news about their missing relatives
secretary was a workplace until three
weeks ago now it's been taken over by
hundreds displaced by the flood
it was the destination for dozens who
drowned last week fleeing from rising
water levels threatening their homes
for nearly three weeks it's been why
Angela Obi and her family called home
times she says are tough for everyone
they shared one bag of rice two bag of
rice and local governments each family
70 milligram
there could also be trust issues
they may give us them property or term
that's material we've got five
that five months before you could go to
this local government this community
everything is finished many areas are
completely cut off and the fate of the
residents still unknown
one of the biggest challenges of
delivering eight victims of the five
year in anambra state is the level of
water two weeks since the flood there is
little sign it's receding but that's not
the only concern here fighters of the
probe they are for separatist movement
are also active in this area
that is said to be a reason why some
officials are staying away
the zonal office of National Emergency
Management agency which covers awka I'm
in anambra state is walking along with
the Nigeria Air Force
to
you know reach out to some of those
communities
eight delivery generally has been slow
and inadequate
victims are concerned that by the time
help arrives it might be too late for
some foreign